like oh my God my skin looks
really good today Jennifer Lopez makeup
free and feeling herself it's about
feeling great looking great yep JLo's
showing off her fresh face in a new
Instagram video posted Tuesday I just
jumped out of the shower and I looked in
the mirror and I was like oh my God my
skin looks
really good today you know you just have
better skin days than others at the end
of the day
Beauty starts from the inside out you
can be youthful and Timeless at every
age it's it's how you feel about
yourself on the inside is a form of
self-love but besides that glow fans are
noticing the start literally wearing her
heart on her chest absolutely why
wouldn't I in the clip Jennifer's
rocking nothing but a towel and gold
necklace spelling out the name of her
hubby Ben Affleck with a heart pendant
what can I tell you we're just having a
good time it's not the first time
Jennifer's subtly honored her man back
in November she shared these snaps
sporting a Jennifer and Ben accessory it
was just perfect yeah the couples made
it clear they're not shy when it comes
to celebrating their rekindled love last
month they debuted matching tattoos on
Valentine's Day it's a beautiful moment
check out Jen's Inc an infinity symbol
with an arrow and both of their names
etched in cursive Ben opted for
something simple two crossed Arrows with
the letters J and V I've never seen any
thing like it at the time A source told
ET they wanted to show their commitment
to each other in a cool fun and unique
way it's a funny thing life and art the
way they kind of intersect adding that
Ben thinks Jen's tat looks sexy and
perfect on her we're super happy
[Music]